[Music]
all right you're up citizens of the
reject Nation hello I'm your boy Aron
here this here is Greg ala that's right
this Mr Greg ala over here he's the man
running the channel of the whole godd
dang thing I don't see how you do let's
go we are here to watch episode two of
invincible today that's right we are
doing the whole dang show and you're
here to join us remember you like this
show you like us remember to ring that
Bell like this video subscribe do all
the things I'm doing good right I would
have said you know subscribe that you
know I when our ration part three is
right right you just subscribe so you
know when reaction part 3 is up don't
forget it are you killing it yeah baby
full length watch alongs are going to be
over on patreon for you super sexy
rejects that's where you go and sync up
with your own copy and you watch along
with us for the full unedited thing over
there on patreon that's where you get
fulllength wasons with Greg and John
covering several shows over there
several exclusives a reaction highlights
and watch alongs included oh my God you
did it yeah baby all right are you ready
to watch this dang old
show did the thing right better than I
expected hell yeah I watched the videos
I've had practice I can do it I can do
the thing and I did the thing I did the
thing today damn it how'd I
do I did the
thing for some of you
it probably seemed like this day would
never come for others it came far too
quickly reinal Val Johnson I look out at
this class and I see hope I see a bright
new world with a special place for each
and every one of you is Mark not at his
own graduation damn it Mark seriously
going to miss his own graduation is he
he's just running a little late he'll be
here he promis how could you miss Mr
Winslow doing the speech for your God
bang High
School Al seismic this whole thing feels
like a Spider-Man episode we got
Spider-Man homecoming here then you got
this Amazing Spider-Man 2 yeah okay yeah
with the with the tower okay I fell into
a new realm of understanding do you know
what this obscene phace is constructed
from he asked expecting some idiotic
answer
uh Granite stolen from the Earth iron
ripped from her loins so did he actually
fall into another realm isn't that most
buildings you can keep the ones made of
wood everything else we're taking back
who's
weird oh no wo I made a few new friends
during my time Underground that's right
they were in
the Montage at the end of last SE season
sometimes life hits you with everything
it's
got like lava now this part's like far
from home cuz got got the magma
Men last time he Adam EES helped to take
on this guy yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah the Earth three claims her stolen
flesh too bad she's out trying to get
her diploma right
now
he's got that chopped down just like his
dad that was great comic book
shot oh hell yeah Mark let's get
it push it to the limit even your
greatest heroes are useless against the
power of
dark that was a solid uppercut punch
nice I that definitely was would have
messed him up he seems like he's a just
a regular dude with tech would have been
better if you had stopped him before he
destroyed another one of America's
greatest treasures it's not destroyed I
could you know I could try pushing it
back
out Abraham Lincoln once said whatever
you are be a good one did he really say
that it doesn't sound very
lincy so all I missed were the made up
inspirational quotes cool
classic and I have is that silver were
you making out with Magma
people I love how there was this big
buildup at the end of last season with
the return of Doc seismic and he just
take it out in the first few minutes of
episode
[Laughter]
two
yeah the original
the
Invincible and it's cracking more what
is this shattering we are leading to is
like another spelling behind it the
shattering
Dimensions oh
yeah peek to the other side or another
side did I tell you guys I'm
volunteering for the Katy Giles campaign
that's your idea of a summer vacation
Giles is the real deal do you even know
your state comproller I don't even know
what a state comproller is I'm with you
William never even heard of it I'm uh
going to go help finish the
Reconstruction up in Chicago that's
amazing Invincible should probably do
that too speaking of
construct more beer she is like Christ
Mark won't even take me flying anymore
boo his to graduation and New
Beginnings Mark damn he seems so goddamn
serious right now the guilt is Weighing
on him he has to do as much as possible
to feel like he's a hero if those seids
ever take over Earth is next we need to
strike first Livingston what what makes
you think I know anything about martians
is that how you say it Martians
[Laughter]
I sure they're bringing back both of
these plots in this episode astronaut
interest oh yep yep no one can blame you
for being a little uh
[Music]
jumping not yourself this is the US
Space Administration not therapy we
don't care about your mental health here
SC about the God dang job but effective
immediately you're taking a temporary
leave till you can get your head on
straight oh wow you really looked out
here actually tried straightening out
his head I get
[Laughter]
it it's crazy knowing how powerful she
actually is especially after the the
special we watched yeah you know how
long I've been Bing the city to clean up
that mess 6
years
what problems is this going to create
though yeah I was thinking that right
cuz I'm like At first like this feels
like a a Side Story you'd see like a
Spider-Man game I'm like okay but what
is what is going to be the ramifications
of her just making things willy-nilly
like
this wow she went all out oh my God
literally made made a park in seconds
will take humans like years to do hey
Mom no no everything's fine great
actually I was just thinking about you
and something wrong he's in the hospital
he's not dead I love him too much to
kill him
off I love her verbally abusive father
too much to die I guess we're both still
a bit raw wow that window open just
keeps that haunted image behind them a
reminder of their past right across the
street what about taking the time to
enjoy your last summer being a
kid man I'm not a kid anymore but that
means making your own choices you don't
have to do everything CA tells you yeah
Mom I kind of do to prove himself I
understand why you think you have to
prove yourself but you don't you're a
good person no one thinks you're going
to turn out like your father then why
would you even say it yeah that's not
what I meant Mark I need you thank god
oh no thank God get pulled away from the
thing that really should be tended
to man The Strain on the Rel
relationship is so tough somebody got me
in the balls maybe if you trained more
and complained less we could get back to
saving lives hey man
Immortal Kate is that you who's Kate in
there with got a boo boo that could use
some dupli
kisses dupli
kisses we are not dating that's
inappropriate language for the workplace
so kiss your own boo boo boo boo huh
what is there something else going doing
that you godamn geriatric hypocrite this
is none of your business damn you and I
were never a thing Immortal and I are
damn I mean look at Immortal come on can
you blame her man's Abraham Lincoln we
honor the guardian's Fallen green doter
Martian Man it's kind of crazy how has
he just been hiding this whole time
right how did he survive cuz it started
off with something small and just just
kind of took over I wonder how much of
the original guy's Consciousness is
still in there Martian Man made Earth
his
home but is it actually Martian Man or
is it a like a someone related I feel
it's someone related yeah cuz the yeah
the actual one died Midnight City been a
virtual No Man's Land since the midnight
magician cursed it back in 02 looks like
Gotham cursed is that like a metaphor no
magic is real
here what it's not
surprising pretty cool huh yeah it was
pretty
dope please somebody help
me whoa God damn it's like a Gothic
cyber Punk World somebody help
me yeah it's like the Batman figure I am
helping what is
happening helping make sure scum like
you never heard another innocent person
again can't be the real version of him
dark queen was at my 12th birthday party
so I'm pretty sure he doesn't kill
people yeah is he like a shape shifter
killed by your father I was night boy
his assistant M Sid kick we don't use
that term it's degrading
grading he's lost it you think you hear
them too huh the voices what oh he's
lost it
huh oh he's
talented he's good he knows what he's
do oh
shoot ow my predecessor developed this
exoskeleton to help even the field
against those like you why didn't he use
it damn how does his speed keep up with
Mark welcome to the shadow verse this is
his land now I'm the hero here I'm
saving the world World from omn man's
son a this is the
fear guess who they'll eat
first you would never like you said I'm
omn man's son a
dude you have no idea what I'm capable
of use the fear against him it's funny
he's using the fear against him yeah guy
who looks like Batman I got to sign off
something just came up anything I can do
I doubt it Debbie oh God she's going to
want Mark to take a break Mark almost
missed his high school graduation
because of you I'm looking out for him
I'm easing him back into the job it's
not a job you can't just order him
around well at least he follows orders
yeah unlike your evil ex-husband I can't
believe you'd even think that after
everything Mark went through and what if
you decide you can't trust him what then
they've given Debbie so much more agency
this time oh yeah I meant what I said
about looking out for Mark no dangerous
stuff until he's ready pres like omin
man there she gets to shine more sir the
Mars file you
requested how is he alive Donald Debbie
are you okay she was just
leaving oh there's a big secret Donald's
not aware is he a clone it's like a
Coulson
situation hey
guys are you and Dad fighting again no
nothing like that well then what I
wonder if it's a spiritual thing because
dark blood revealed he was an
atheist be kind of
ironic
Samantha her powers are so broken dude
it's insane she's God essentially what
are you doing in a burger March shirt
it's called an honest day's work took
Mark's job Furniture story you've been
there for 20 years until you people turn
the Chicago corporate office into a pile
of rubble why didn't you tell me maybe
you should have asked instead of flying
off to God knows where doing God knows
what you are such a prick I can give you
and Mom whatever you want I've provided
for this family longer than you've been
alive oh man your pride is
awful there 24
[Laughter]
Karat I said change it back man's Pride
I know I would take advantage of my da
daughter's abilities she's offering it
to you on a golden apple I can't you
just produce money yeah just give just
make bills that's all you really need
I'm taking you to lunch ooh
ooh there's this great thae place down
the street uh I had somewhere else in
mind oh my God just like his dad take
her on any trip ever take her to Europe
my
God you brought me to
Paris sort
of is that a casino Vegas ah nice yeah
so it's just Las Vegas you only get an
hour for lunch and I can't fly you the
year up that fast without your skin
ripping
off that's real how fast can you fly to
Vegas fast enough to turn into jelly
Mark I need you dinner tonight instead
go save the world Invincible you just
got to Vegas make make sure the voice in
your ear isn't the only one you listen
to yeah listen to let them die have fun
with your
girlfriend is she lever there damn also
I need to take you back to work first
okay you're late for what low tide
something like that turns out the
atlantans are sore about omn man
murdering their King aquaris oh my God
atlantan law dictates that his sentence
falls to his next of kin you oh you want
me to go to war against an entire
underwater civilization according to
atlantan custom the only way to atone
for the king's murder is to marry his
widow oh there you go I can't marry a
fish strictly symbolic all you have to
do is go through the ceremony maybe kiss
the bride and All Is Forgiven and
everyone moves on and easy oh Cil what a
Croc of conate couldn't have told
him first do the fish sleep with the
fish sorry kid I got another fire to put
out good luck down there I'll be
listening
yeah you going to listen to that getting
freaky with a fish
girl the lizard League call me back for
the lizard League they've hit a bio
research lab outside of Dallas the
serpent Society it appears that Supreme
lizard has seized control in his
absence it's just a guy in a lizard suit
that's
awesome and I'm not doing another
me that me better not be you
Rudy I call me the shapes Smith the shap
sh there is a shape shifter this
[Music]
hey wow cool Atlantis just like the
Aquaman
movie you've got to saved the world and
just a kissy fish I can't do this and
definitely not here in in front of
everyone okay the this is kind of
awkward but I have a
girlfriend isn't that why I'm here to be
your new king why would I need a king oh
then we're not getting married we
abolish that barbaric custom what do you
think we are
savages what's the plan her to kill him
thank you your your majesty what's the
plan her Mark's going to have to kill
the fish people cuz they want to kill
him so what's a new law trial by my
combat release the death dweller kill
the fish this sucks he has to pay the
consequences for what his dad did sins
of the father what
the it's a
Pokemon it's plushy oh no it's just a
tip it's just a
tip it's like
SpongeBob it's like the the clam tongue
with the old
lady
you love
interest uh if you're not feeling ready
let's sell this this place is
adorable we'll take
it when are you taking offers Wednesday
whoa slow down I was just asking well
don't bother we're definitely not
offering on this place what's this guy's
problem when you earn the money you can
decide where we live oh no Debbie she's
not your
pet why don't to take the rest of the
day off I'll call you later Debbie you
need to get over your stop
projecting Debbie yeah Debbie everyone's
gone through
stuff not
[Laughter]
special what the hell's going on down
there your file on atlantan law needs
some serious
updating I'm pulling you out back up own
way
sedu it Merc break the chains and take
it to land so you can whip its ass
[Laughter]
damn he keeps going up against
these Sonic Blast thingies give him a
Sonic
clap
[Music]
sound God damn mark one day you will
live up to your
title how far away is that get your lens
cracked in the second
episode great good
backup oh no it's attacking the people
now oh
no oo yikes damn prove you're not your
dad be a hero I can't leave those people
to die they tried to kill you all they
wanted was Justice for what my dad did
you're not your father prove it
Mark disobey those orders oh I feel this
this is really good going back aw you
ain't your daddy
[Music]
boy I like these like flashes this
Implement
show
ooh
[Music]
come on Mark hat that cinematic music
very much
so smart let the weight pull it down
descend to the depths of the
Abyss I kick some dirt Over the Hole
spit on it no
oh uh what the hell
inom Atlantis is calling it even since
you saved the Queen's life the next time
I give you an order you listen even if
it's the morally right
choice give it to the boys in R&D I want
to report in a week yes sir what sir
when Debbie came to speak with you she
seemed distressed when she saw me and
she's a distressed person why bring
Donald back out of anyone must have some
bigger role in this season or something
maybe he is in love with him
[Laughter]
it's a secret lover you had your job for
years and losing it must feel awful I
know how hard you work to provide for
Mom and me no one is trying to take that
away from you it feels like it has no
purpose now I'm trying to help like you
help Chicago the whole lot was unstable
that's why the city never built there
oh oh
no
ramifications your powers don't make you
a hero they make you d dangerous I have
to go don't come back until you figure
that out out of the
ear try to do something good just
backfires so Much Death oh she's going
to SP she's going to break it rip it off
his
hinges yep you
mother
yep
would have thought they' make Debbie
such a compelling ass character this
season a clean this up
[Music]
[Laughter]
pet a hand over
heart oh they're both struggling
like we don't know anything about the
shapes Smith I can tell you I was born a
baby human right here on on the planet
of
Earth I don't believe
you oh it's um homeboy yeah yeah oh oh
oh I got my superpowers in a random
industrial
accident oh God creepy as hell I swore
to use my abilities for good and to help
people and to protect my Planet no
matter what the invasion we will rise
again
any day now all H Supreme liard all
h g shot
[Music]
oh damn anyone is going to turn this
organization around it's going to be
king lizard any objections I guess not I
can't argue with that know anything
about you
guys another breakout who who the hell
are you anyway think of me as an old
friend given your current predicament
fine wait what not the universe then
they just wore me down cought me when I
finally had to sleep Dam okay okay so
there's a way to defeat him who the hell
are you oh that's what I
said I'm not your problem then whose
problem are you well not his but close
enough hey you promised you'd help me
hey
fascinating what's your play
guy's trying to get whatever answers he
can to defeat him
yeah
okay all right was that was good I liked
it there's a lot of good stuff in
there I think I liked the first episode
a little bit more but I did enjoy the
the journey
here yeah wow wow wow wow it's quite uh
it's quite a lot of energy you've
brought
[Laughter]
here okay guys this was the greatest
episode ever
uh no man I think that you know there's
a lot of interesting stuff in here from
the uh grieving of both um Debbie and
and Mark and how they go about that and
yeah Alice's relationship and finally
seeing the ramifications of that and
like her trying to help and really
coming into her powers and yeah I think
there's just a lot of really interesting
things that they're uh they're planning
forward I the thing that that kind of
caught my eye the most though is like
you know Debbie's individual Arc and how
we're really getting to hone in on her
more and that Coming to Terms or that
coming uh at the end meeting mark where
he's at and what I'm hoping for is like
I know this season so far is very much
devoid of omn man but I would like to
not have omn man in this season or at
least for like 99% of it so that way
like we see these characters grow and
like find some semblence of healing and
moving forward and right when that
happens omn man reenters the
picture I would agree with you but I
think our videos will get more views
when omn man's
here and to me that's above storytelling
it's view
count and if we want I what's the point
of doing it if we're not getting views
you want the money I'd rather have omn
man I'd rather complain about a poor
story with omn man if that equates to
more views then less views and talk
about good
storytelling you know when you say that
I guess it makes a lot of sense you know
we just need omn man here need omn he's
the homelander of this
show I'm just saying have him shows
nothing without him I'm just saying well
his presence uh lingers throughout you
know whether be in the consequences of
Mark with dealing with the people of
Atlantis or the fish fish beings of
Atlantis yeah and I like how it presents
an opportunity for him to provide
restoration like a real moment of choice
where he could have just extracted
Revenge really demonstrating how he's
not like his father MH I thought was a
beautiful moment I I was very I was very
much touched by that
moment what they're dealing with uh
Debbie is something that
I I'm glad it's in the season and I
expected that we do something I wasn't
expecting it to be such a powerful AFF
effect that would consistently carry
through as an arc for not just Debbie
but for Debbie and Mark's
relationship and that is the thing that
I am personally the most gravitated
toward in terms of what the show
sensibilities are like they're keeping
everything on a on a much more personal
grounded level like with Adam Eve you
know at the beginning there's
such Joy um being demonstrated to the
public of look what we can do as hero
and look how we can change the lives and
then not thinking about certain things
of you know it's it's almost
metaphorical in a way of the foundation
is not properly assembled so trying to
build a new structure on top of a weak
foundation will make everything crumble
and you could say that like mentally
socially psychologically for all of our
characters who try to do forms of
escapism you know like Mark even wanted
to avoid a convers a tough conversation
with his mom by fighting something bad
out there in the world you know it it's
I think they're doing a lot of
interesting things uh thematically
honestly like uh I'm like I'm really
liking a lot of this it's very different
than the first season where I am trying
to grasp a s like the post credit scenes
have been helping to grasp a sense of
the direction of the Season MH because
the end of the last season would kind of
have you go all right everyone should
just be gathering and readying
themselves for the return of omn man or
of the vulture M coming in to try to
dominate and that hasn't really been the
focus no at all at all and and I would
like it to kind of go back to that a
tiny even if it's not even if it's not
including Omni
man I would like some of the focus to go
back to that um Cliffhanger that we had
of last season that warning of the of
the
inevitable you know and that that little
inkling is is kind of missing for me a
little bit but we're only two episodes
in yeah I still think that that meeting
hasn't happened yet cuz I feel like that
would be like the top of his mind if you
know that what me the one with Allan the
yeah the one Alan the the alien yeah
like hey your dad's coming he's going to
take over the planet cuz it hasn't
really even been mentioned at all you
feel like that's and especially with him
dealing with the fact that he does have
this weight on his shoulders of being
compared to his father you think that'd
be something that's on the Forefront of
his mind the fact that his dad and his
people are coming so I think within the
context of the story does it wouldn't
make sense for that to have happened in
us not to mention it and yeah cuz
clearly that at that point there was a
time Jump well they're bringing back
they brought back a lot of things here
because you're dealing with not just the
grievance
ramifications you're dealing
with um Cliffhangers of last season you
know like Doc seismic comes back and
he's taking out pretty fast yeah maybe
that's just going to be a thing every
season because last EP he had like a
whole episode you know with Mount
Rushmore with Adam Eve and where he gets
knocked in the volcano pit and then at
the end of um last season they showed he
was still alive with these lava beings
whatever and I was surprised by how
after setting that up at the end of last
season that they kind of just got
resolved well maybe we're not done with
it maybe there's still more to do
because like um da Sinclair from the the
last season we thought he'd be like a
one and done they started to use him
more yeah so that could be a silver
situation here well we also have um the
armor mob
guy um arm mob guy with the with the
who's like who's like Luke Cage guy oh
yeah yeah yeah who's like a mobster now
he like trick Mark into helping him
become the Kingpin yeah yeah that like
we still have that that we're probably
going to bring back because this was
this was like bringing back stuff like
story lines that were not resolved yeah
we're still in the reestablishing stage
of this like we're still like the
ramifications of the immed the immediacy
of last season before we really said
what's to come in the Forefront we had
the Martians and that whole thing thing
with like the uh parasite version of the
alien encounter when Mark was away on
Mars and they were saying like just
takes one and then we saw that it took
over one now we're having to deal with
that we're going to see how that's going
to factor in to whatever malevolent
threat that forms and and with it being
at the Guardians HQ being one of the
bigger threats now they're introducing
the lizard people which is kind of
whatever to me I'm like not that
interested in it but we'll we'll see
imagine yeah I imagine that's going to
be our our immediate villain of the week
so to speak thing that happens within
the next episode but I don't know I feel
like this show is really smart about
taking these comic book tropes and then
kind of elevating them in a way because
like they're they're really at this
point in the show really focus on
focusing on humanizing uh all of our
characters and where we are so I feel
like all that stuff that they're setting
up is going to be thematically relevant
to the characters once we finally get
into the full swing of what the basis of
this entire season's going to be yeah
yeah I mean I like the multiversal setup
of this uh of the guy Sterling Cape
Brown is playing and I'm I'm just very
curious to see how it ultimately unfolds
to where any of this really M because
because there's a lot of threads that
they're dealing with there's a lot of
characters and it's I feel like it's at
risk of feeling a little convoluted it
could yeah they got to be very careful
with how they kind of craft this season
because we we have threads that they're
establishing that have been started with
in this season they have stuff They're
bringing back from last season yeah and
yeah how that all comes together I don't
know I will say that I'm curious about
Sterling C Brown's character so far but
I'm not like on the edge of my seat
about it you know because I feel like
with omn man in season one with him
being the big threat there was this
looming you started off with this big
mystery of like oh my God why did ay man
do this and then you just have this
character that's done this horrible
thing that everybody know that nobody
knows but we the audience know and it's
just like this it's like okay when's it
going to break when when things going to
come to the there's more personal
entanglement exactly and there's a more
personal involvement with it as well but
now we have this guy who's like largely
removed from our immediate uh cast of
characters and the only experience we
have with this universe's version of of
Mark having encountered this guy is what
seeing him in a machine and then it
blowing up so I wonder how much time
you're going to give our main cast or at
least our main character uh to have some
semblance of connection with our new
villain well it seems like they're going
to have something where it it opens up
the door for some type of crazy Universe
building event yeah where the stakes can
be higher than ever and I I feel like
we'll get like not just omn man but a
different vulture might to come in yeah
I think my only question that could be
something of concern is that
okay the omn man threat is something
that's of this universe something that's
personal and something that's coming as
far as what the last season established
with something like a Multiverse plot
you're kind of opening it up to
something bigger than granted less
personal but something bigger than what
we established in the last season so I'm
like how are you guys going to go ultra
big and then back down to something uh
small and personal and like make that
still um satisfying well the c k Brown
character is figuring out ways to get
rid of omn man and and and Invincible
yeah you know like he they're he's
finding universes where they can be
defeated he's and so that makes it
scarier for Mark who's still like in in
an amateur time like I'm I'm loving the
animation and I'm loving um how C cesil
is dealing is dealing with having Mark
and and seeing if he can truly still
trust this guy or and for Mark having to
still work around trying to form his own
identity of no I can make my my own
choices and that doesn't mean I'm going
to make the wrong villainous choices
like my dad like it's almost as if he
relies on C Cecil to keep himself under
control to not conform to the dark side
and I think he needs to have that level
of acknowledgement like it's still very
character driven and there there's a lot
of things that I'm I'm latching on to
and I it's like you can't first season
you have eight episodes and we like two
episodes in and I I'm liking that it's
different I'm just sort of waiting to
see how it all ends before I'm like
which one do I like more but there is a
Darkness that's looming throughout all
this that I'm really enjoying and I
think the animation is very striking and
I'm loving um just anytime with the
intimate character development like the
the act it it breathes better than last
season it's like and I think it's earned
that level of breathing yeah it doesn't
have to earn you over like the the last
season or the first season did you know
like okay we know we have our audience
so we can allow things to be a little
bit slower we still teasing things to
come
yeah yeah yeah um be but right now we do
have plots that do feel like separated
and I want them to feel a little bit
more connected because you got mark on
his own adventure but he's got nothing
to do with the Guardians right you know
largely removed from that whole plot and
Cecil's running both and it's like well
I want to and before it was
like is that an intentional move from
Cecil to keep Mark away from the
Guardians because before it was omn man
who was not under Cecil's rule did not
worked for him but was always teaming up
with the Guardians right right you know
and then you got a moral learn uh being
the established leader again and then
watching whatever riffs happen there
yeah and he has mistrust of Mark so
maybe that's proba he's not part of the
team yeah yeah exactly like there's
there's all these qualities you got
Amber doing whatever the hell Amber's
doing you know like you have this scene
with the oh yeah you got the the guy the
I forget the name of him the son of him
too of like that's opening up this
this guy before that guy was just Batman
in the last season and then now his his
number his number two is has like
special suit and his super fast and
could do like magical abilities I'm like
how was this guy the number two why was
he a why was he a c um you know sidekick
some where he seems like so much more
powerful you know had all this Tech may
I don't maybe I can I can only imagine
maybe um this the original midnighter
had this Tech but like he reserved uh he
used some because of like ethics or
something but now this guy is just like
screw it I'm just going to use all of
the tools I have at my disposal to keep
Society safe in his own way yeah there's
just like a lot happening right now yeah
there's a lot of setup for sure and I
wonder if it's going to be able to
balance and pay off everything yeah I
like the things that they're setting up
but again it's just like how are they
going to land all of it yeah yeah I am I
am on the verge of like is it going to
become comp because what what I care
about I really care about and there
times I'm like oh this is cool this is
new this is fascinating and I'm always
I'm always enjoying it I'm always liking
what's in front of me um I guess I my
mind's getting a little caught up down
the road of like is this going to become
too much yeah I'm really curious of
where uh where Alice Eve no Adam Eve is
gonna go yeah and uh yeah what's because
she's essentially God in this universe
and she has these PE her parents in her
life that kind of make her
question like her not her purpose I
guess but like if she is doing actual
good you know like her dad's like that
that insecure voice in her head yeah
yeah and yeah I wonder what's going to
become of that cuz she has the power to
do pretty much anything can live
anywhere can she could probably stop all
of this crime by herself if she wanted
to um in a way I mean like she's like Dr
Manhattan I don't think she realizes her
full po potential yet oh yeah cuz she I
don't think she's accessed that that God
State I think when she did the Adam Eve
like she accessed God state in the Adam
Eve special I don't think she was fully
aware yeah so that's probably something
that's going to come back in this
season alrighty well yeah so far I still
give this episode at least an eight out
of 10 um and I'm excited to see where we
go I mean there's a reason they're
releasing them like this yeah and so I'm
excited to see how it all unfolds or
would you rate it Aaron same I would say
like a 7.5 I think I like the the first
episode a little bit more but I think
it's still really good yeah yeah I'm
enjoying it it's a good show it's stays
good or would you rank it out of uh all
the episodes that I've ever aired that's
hard how about you just rank how about
you just rank all the episodes right now
right now top 10 list Mojo watch Mojo
style I don't know man what do you what
do you rank it out of all the episodes
oh this is probably number uh six for me
six yeah yeah what's what's last last
it's the worst episode of the show um
I'll probably say uh I'm not the biggest
fan of the dark seismic episode yeah you
didn't like it that much I mean I liked
it but it's my least favorite okay it's
like a it's like a classic villain of
the week kind of feel to that
one it's yeah it's okay I feel it I
don't know I don't I don't have a a hard
ranking yet I think so I need to need to
sit with it need to let my my mental
processes breathe a little bit I'll come
back I'll come back you next week and
tell you where everything ranks top to
bottom
top all right guys
well say hi to Aaron close us out Aaron
all right guys thanks for watching y'all
are the the best the sexiest rejects
there are in the land keep on watching
we're going to keep on doing this dang
thing and uh yeah you're
beautiful how how you doing how's
that that you do I don't know I don't
know we're doing it all right you guys
I'll see you guys next time bye go to
some
[Music]
accent